What I want to do in this
video is compare investment
to consumption.
And we're going to think
about it in two contexts.
One I would call the everyday
conventional context.
And then the other
one would be how
we would think about it
in an economics context.
Because these words
mean something
very particular to an economist.
And that's important that it
means something particular,
because we're going
to start using
these words, or
this terminology,
or these classifications,
to understand
where GDP is coming from.
So in everyday-- let me
draw a line over here.
This is going to be
everyday or, conversational,
versions of this term.
And down here, we'll
put the economics,
the economic versions
of this term,
especially when we think of it
in the context of accounting
for GDP.
And they're not necessarily
all that different.
But they are different
in important ways.
So in investment,
really in both cases,
you can generally
view it as something
that you do to get
some future gain.
So for example, if I today build
a house-- so I build a house.
So that is the house.
I built it today.
And this will be the timeline.
The house will keep lasting.
And it's an investment,
because it's
going to be giving
me future gain.
A year from now, I'll still
be able to live in that house.
So I will have the saved rent.
That's a future gain, a future
gain two years from now.
It'll keep giving
some type of gain.
You could have a financial
instrument, maybe
some type of debt instrument.
You're lending money
to someone else.
So maybe you buy a bond,
which is essentially you
lending money to someone else.
That is an investment in
the everyday sense of it.
Because when have that asset,
when you've bought that asset,
it's going to pay off
something in the future.
It's going to pay off some
interest or some profits.
And in the everyday sense,
I would consider something
like-- hopefully
it would be-- going
to college would
be an investment.
So education, I'll
say education,
because you invest that time
and energy and education, it's
going to keep paying off.
Hopefully by doing
that, you're going
to get better employment
and higher wages
the rest of your life.
It will keep paying off.
So this is the everyday
notion of investment.
The everyday notion
of consumption,
the way I think about it,
is you are buying something
or you're doing something
that you're just
going to use up
in the short-term.
And just by using it up,
whatever that object is,
if you just use it up-- and it's
just going to hopefully benefit
you in some way, but it's
more of a short-term thing--
I would consider
that consumption
in the everyday sense.
So if you go buy a
candy bar and eat it,
you have consumed the candy bar.
You have not made an investment.
If you go to a movie,
that is consumption.
And I'm not making
any value judgment
that one is better
than the other.
Investment, at the
end of the day,
you're investing so that you
can get future benefit that
could lead to consumption.
Because at the end of
the day, consumption
is one of the things that might
make your life a little bit
better off.
So I'm not saying that one
is better than the other.
But watching a movie, that
would also be consumption.
Spending time buying
a book, well, you
could debate whether
that's education or not.
But let's say you buy a book
that is not educational,
that is consumption.
But it is making you happier.
Hopefully, it's making your
life better in some way.
Now, the economic
definitions are
related to these
everyday definitions,
but they're a little
bit more precise.
And they make the
definitions in a way
that they're easier to account
for if you are a nation.
They're easier to keep track of.
So the way an economist
would define it,
they would define
economic investment
as spending on
capital equipment.
Capital equipment are things
like, if you are a factory,
you will buy the equipment
to run your factory.
You buy the robots.
And you buy the assembly line.
And you buy the wheelbarrows
or whatever else,
the things that have
to cart things around.
That is capital equipment.
It would be things
like inventory.
So for example, the
inventory-- and this
is still not so different.
Both of these things
are being used
to produce things in the future,
to produce future benefit.
You're buying that inventory,
sometimes raw material,
you're going to add value to it.
And then they're
going to be used
to produce something
in the future.
It includes things like even
the structures, the buildings.
And so for all of this, in
the economic sense, and this
is why it's easier to account
for, this, for the most part,
is being done by the firms.
And it also includes the one
thing that households do,
which is construction
of new homes.
This is from the households.
Actually, the buying
of a house does not
show up in consumption
or investment,
because nothing
new was produced.
Something just exchanged hands.
So whenever we talk about
any of these things,
especially when we're
talking about it
in precise economic
terms, it's the production
of new capital equipment, new
inventory, new structures,
new homes.
If I just buy a factory
from someone else,
that does not add to GDP.
It would not be considered
investment or consumption,
because I'm just
transferring an asset
from one person to another.
It would only be added to
GDP when it is first created.
And on the consumption
side, from an economic point
of view-- let me draw a little
bit of a line right over here--
consumption is considered to
be any spending on final goods
by households except
for new homes.
And let me make
this even clearer.
Because remember, if we're
just transferring goods,
that shouldn't count.
So let me put it on newly
produced final goods.
Now, what's unintuitive
a little bit over here
is, according to the way we
account for GDP, the tuition
that you spend on a
college education,
that is new spending
on final goods.
And here are the final
goods or services.
The service you're
getting is your education.
That would be consumption.
So education would fall
here in the economic sense.
While in the every day sense, I
would consider education right
over here.
Maybe you are buying a car.
And you're not buying a
car for leisure purposes.
You're buying a car because you
need your car to go to work.
There's an argument
that that would
be an investment in
the everyday sense.
By having that car,
you have something
that can take you
to work every day.
So you're getting
future benefit.
So there's an argument
that maybe that's
an investment in
the everyday sense.
But in the accounting sense,
that car would sit right here.
You bought a new car.
But that is considered
consumption.
You did not buy a new house.
And the whole reason, at
least as far as I understand,
why it's set up this way is this
is this easier to account for.
You look at all of
the spending by firms,
that's easy to account for.
You essentially call
that investment.
Because at the end of
the day, all the spending
that firms are making
is they're doing
it to produce some
good or service.
So we call this investment any
spending that the firms do.
And on top of that, when
households purchase new homes,
we also call that investment.
And that's just easier
for the accounting offices
of governments to keep track of.
And everything else
that households do,
we consider consumption.
And we'll see in
the next few videos,
there are a few other
categories in terms
of things that
the government do.
And then we'll have to think
about imports and exports.